voters in Texas are heading to the polls
today and statewide primary elections
and they'll see an historic number of
women on ballots more than 160 women
across the state of Texas are competing
in local state and federal primaries
it's all part of a national wave of
women seeking public office some of them
for the first time Jan Crawford visits
Dallas visited Dallas rather to meet for
first-time female candidates she's with
us now from Capitol Hill Jan good
morning good morning you know look women
make up more than half of the country
but less than 20% of the lawmakers here
on Capitol Hill and in Texas those
numbers are even lower so this year
women across Texas and across the
country are trying to change that hey
we're gonna have this Town Hall for
first-time candidates running for office
is a baptism by fire to be a candidate
you blow open your comfort zone being
the person you actually running is a lot
different Julie Johnson and Anna Maria
Ramos are Democrats running for the
Texas Legislature Republicans June
Sarver and Jaime Blanco are running for
Congress they all agree it's time for a
different approach to politics and
people want somebody to solve problems
and get things done and I think that's a
characteristic you hear about women
running all that is happening is
bickering and fighting you know we have
kids that bicker and fight and we saw
that every day nearly 500 women are
likely running for Congress a new record
and roughly 200 more or exploring bids
for statewide offices nearly 70 percent
are Democrats
Debbie Walsh tracks female candidates at
the Center for American women in
politics we saw this increase start to
happen almost immediately after the 2016
presidential election and I think much
of this has been in response to the
election of Donald Trump for Johnson and
Ramos Hillary Clinton's defeat felt
personal I was devastated
I was devastated I didn't immediately
decide I needed to run I just knew that
I needed to bump it up a notch the
women's March was really instrumental
March after March of cities all across
the country and this outpouring of women
saying enough is enough the increase in
Republican women running has been much
smaller but Blanco and Sarver also found
inspiration in 2016 and I don't like the
tone of our party right now do I step
back and wait or do I dive in and try to
make it better I want to stand next to
the president and praise the policies I
agree with when he's governing with
conservative principles but also be
willing to call it the politics and the
rhetoric I think that our party's
forgetting that it is the women the
Republican Party has so many Republican
women clubs everywhere and they are
actually the heartbeat of everything if
we sat down and had coffee together even
though we're Republicans and Democrats
we could come up with some very
meaningful solutions I think that's
exactly why you're seeing so many women
run now these women have obvious
differences on policy questions the size
of government and they're in competitive
races like most candidates across the
country but regardless of whether they
win or lose they said they are going to
keep working to find solutions
bianna some big changes in my home state
Jan thank you